you were cancelled no no hold on hold on
hold on a lot of people were cancelled I
was investigated by the Department of
Justice so you're the queen of cancel
who put me under an investigation put me
on the no fly list interrogated me under
oath and were considering charging me
with conspiracy to assassinate the
president of the United States for
holding that dollar for taking a picture
yes so all the other folks that were
cancelled and maybe had a bad week you
know different animal it was lawyering
up etc etc so and you know the mag up
folks are still angry with me and I've
had several I've been in battled in many
legal cases since then I keep getting
sued by Maga people I have a case
outstanding in federal court in
Tennessee and if you two would like to
come with me to any of those appearances
is that the one where youcome isn't that
the one where the guy was making he got
fired from an app yeah because he was
making a home phobic uh somebody taped
him making homophobic harassing these
trans kids getting their prom picture
taken at a Lobby of a hotel so I did a
couple tweets about it which is a long
career of advocacy for the queer
community and so the guy decided to sue
me as if I'm the reason he got fired not
his own behavior but you know these
cases take years to cycle through the
system and so I had two cases in
Kentucky one in State Court one in
federal court you know so it's been like
a whole thing did you an anticipate when
you were doing I know you probably
anticipated the shock value of what you
were going to do in the photo but do did
you anticipate the blowback that you
were going to get not only did I not
anticipate it I didn't think the shock
value would be that much because I
thought first of all I didn't have a
publicist at the time I was in between
gigs and so I'm so deess that I thought
you know what I'm not doing anything why
don't I just do a funny photo shoot so I
called a shooter that I had worked with
once before and we did other photos that
day like I did one of my then nextdoor
neighbor Kim
Kardashian and her husband at the time
Kanye West two years next door neighbors
wow take it in anyway they were by the
way dream neighbors I know that sounds
funny she's my neighbor now she's I love
her she's no drama the last thing she
wanted to do was cause drama in the
neighborhood so they were actually
amazing neighbors and boy do they have
security so that was fun um which I also
kind of needed at the time and so um
I thought that this photo will maybe
live on like a couple of gay blonds I
didn't I didn't think it was all that
shocking it was a Halloween mask I
personally felt like as a woman you know
I sort of felt in need to do a shocking
photo about him because I find him to be
a shocking guy I know him as you do if
you worked at NBC Universal as I did for
20 years he was everywhere he was
ubiquitous but you know you'd see him at
publicity events and
um you know when theyd roll out the new
seasons that's when my life on the D
list was in and stuff and I I never knew
this part of trump I always thought he
was just kind of this bloviating kind of
character you know so I'm getting
nervous because I'm waiting for you to
say most of the listeners of the show
are trumpers no CU you probably cross
over you're probably well I just don't
talk I don't talk politic we don't talk
so I don't mean to go too deep on that
but you can go deep you can go as deep
as you want I'm just listening I and and
I I don't want to alienate people you're
not alienating people on this show
there's nobody gets alienated okay good
because I'm just you know as a woman and
as a woman of a certain age I found the
stuff he did Beyond shocking and so I
thought let's take sort of a protest
photo some people thought it was funny
that's fine with me too I don't care but
no I never could have anticipated it and
what I learned for you know and since
then is because I've gotten a couple of
foas freedom information acts and the
Oval Office first of all it came
directly from the Oval Office which is
shocking to me that the sitting
president would be like make this a
priority they were very serious about
charging me with that crime which is
also shocking to me because I thought
okay well he's going to make me
miserable but they're not going to
really charge me with the crime they
called my lawyer um and you know my
lawyer you can ask him this every day
because they desperately wanted me to go
downtown and they wanted footage of a
per walk so they wanted like a
helicopter that would see me being like
walked into the downtown Elli
Precinct um and that there was a moment
where you really believe that you were
going to be charged yeah well I never
spent a moment not taking that seriously
so I spent a long time you know
practicing with my first amendment
attorney who by the way is the real guy
in the movie The People versus Larry
Flint the real guy that Edward Norton
plays yeah is my first amendment
attorney because I'm thinking if he can
defend Larry Flint then damn it I'm a
walk in the park but um it was a lot lot
of wrangling with the lawyers and the
two government agencies the Secret
Service and the US attorney's office
just to keep them from charging me and
so that was just so much to deal with
and so once again like and expensive
insanely expensive like over a million
dollars really yes oh well hold on I
should say I also am throwing in my
security bills because the stuff people
would do to me if I ventured out of the
house was so scary like I can't tell you
how many people if I was just walking
down the street would approach me and be
furious and get in my face and turn red
and you know because let me tell you
these trumpers they're hardcore they are
hardore I've never seen anything like
it